peace the solution for humanity
please bismillah and hundred assalamu
alaikum me you know the greeting that's
that greeting of peace peace be unto you
and today we have with us on the Deen
show i met with hatun that's right he's
gonna be sharing his experiences his
story with us here on the DC
Allah there's only one bad and Jesus was
his messenger Allah why did that maybe
it maybe it's just to break the ice with
you you're on the D show this is
exciting so you are in the Muslim world
and do lots of non not yet Muslims
listen to hear your songs also you're a
vocalist you sing what would you call it
and the sheet art is what was the title
finishing doctors what does that mean
machine
the sheet is like it's it's singing
without the instruments basically the
music music instruments just voice yeah
just with the noise so you do different
songs and what's usually the context of
your songs what are they singing about
what are you singing about and basically
the idea comes from what is happening
around me you know if I see that there's
a problem is no social problems and say
I can I can address them to the
intonation of the people then we just
write about it as a poetry is concerned
and then you compose the music and then
I sing it sometimes that I think about
the last part I let some time I think it
was the prophets or Arsenal and
sometimes I think about ethics
I think about Family Values
so it's different actually I mean it's
not just that what I say that at the
moment you don't sing about like going
to the nightclubs and men and women and
like the 50 cent some good stuff it had
a message has every every let's say
every song yeah has a message for
example if I'm calling people is it to
come close to Allah
- God you know I'm asking them you know
feel close to Arles France are they how
happy your life would be and if you are
away from Allah so I thought and then
you see that all the doors are closed in
front of you you know so and and really
people you know when they listen to the
machine they actually start you know we
put this house and the place you know
that of the person who's singing and
they think that yes he's right a lot of
people change the course of their lives
just you know by listening to something
which affected them so a lot of people
put themselves in such situations and
then they realize that you know that if
they come closer to Allah sponsor
they'll be happy the same issues let's
say for example if I take a song about
stable people disabled people they have
a message for example to us that we're
not we're not going okay we are disabled
but we're not disabled mentally
we're not disabled those feelings voice
we we are strong we try but it comes to
us as human beings and were normal you
know we are actually we've we've we
whine about everything we do complain of
a complaint in life but Angela we have
our eyes or hands or legs you know we
can we have all these gifts from Allah
Samantha which we should be happy with
so this is an issue I had to address
because back in my country we never knew
that there was a place for disabled
people and when we came to know that
there is a place for the same people I
went myself when I am visited them and I
saw them and I thought that you know
that they want me to to know that
they're there
they're like you know they're poor and
they're like they cannot do this and
there show mercy but they didn't want
that they wanted me to know that they
are strong and they can try and they can
get up and and this is what I did you
know I went and I found this best poem
which she talks about you know I saw
this girl she had only one leg but she
still smiled it was a girl you talking
about who only had one she's so smile
yeah this isn't your one year yes it's
called forgive
so I when I see her smiling and seeing
that she only has one leg and the other
leg is not there and I said to myself
like God forgive me when I whine I have
two legs what am i complaining yeah you
know and then I see another guy was
blind you know and I don't know he's
blind but but when I try to because he's
telling me something and I pay him he
doesn't he doesn't take the money and
he's blind but you know and I say to
myself he still smiled and he's he's
just living his life so normal without a
corny complaining so again this is a
description of what's going on in your
song
it's your singing it has a girl who now
is one leg we're complaining whining but
look you got both your legs and now
you're talking about the blind for
exactly he's he's also happy when he's
blind but he's accepted himself East has
peace with his problem it hasn't ever
any problem with being blind they just
accepted it but but we have the eyes and
we never said Allah thank you for this
bliss for this blessing I have I have
this I have the eyes I can see
everything you know sometimes I imagine
I just close my eyes for five minutes
and I imagine that if I was blind or for
birds I would tell that I was scared
I'll feel insecure now I don't know what
to do I had someone to help me to guide
me so alhamdulillah I mean this is this
is actually like the message that you
know that thank Allah for the for the
let's say for the gifts you have the
same thing with the ears the same thing
with I mean this is what I'm trying to
do I mean if there is a problem which
people I can see the people are not been
for example aware of I try to address it
yeah it's almost 4:00 hour not yet
Muslim audience they heard you say an
Arabic word we always love to define
these words on the Deen show you said
Allah is this some Arab and who is alone
unless prantera is the one God don't God
yes one God which we have to worship Him
only and that's why we say la ilaha illa
Allah yes you know Muhammad Allah Salih
I don't know I mean you use there's no
god but the one guy so just so they can
assuage any fear because some people say
Allah if you like
era back or this is the moon no no no
we're talking about the one guy who
created the Sun in the moment God is
like okay if you see there are many many
gods yes
which people worship different gods okay
but our God is Allah yes his name wasn't
long it's not like for example when I
say may God be with you but which God
which God can some people take Atreus
God exactly I thought about to take
differences some people think Jesus
exactly yes is it true before just on
this point do Christians also Jewish or
also Arabic speaking do they use the
word Allah they do some of them use it
up yeah rub is also another word for a
person was responsible for something sir
Lord it's like yeah it's like a little
hoard okay like for example a family a
family man would be responsible for his
wife and children so he was we will say
in Arabic or Abu Salah what I as a
family yeah yeah so Allah smart either
is my lord yeah bad I bet this is the
sleeves yes so that's what we want to
just delete it any fear and now we will
take a break and we'll be back for more
in addition when outside everything
looks good you see the hundred thousand
dollar car you see a lot of diamonds you
see a lot of females and they think that
this is you know this is a life this is
this is like you know paradise right
here
with the job to go into someone's heart
to change the heart your job is to topi
what the truthers and the alley of it is
while we're sitting here while I'm
sitting here constantly paying for the
disease to kill was free
I saw bubble down meow she had Warleggan
or a crowd but she passed she smiled
Oh God forgive me one
when I
all go back to the den show I'm here
ultimate haunted and just for some
people many of the Muslims they know who
you are for the not yet Muslims this is
like the equivalent let's say forgive me
if I give a bad example but in the
Muslim world kind of like Michael
Jackson meaning that in popularity you
know because of your beautiful melodious
song that you sing that are praising God
talking about the good things and you're
not singing you know and unique thing is
you don't use any instruments this is
all voices but I want to know and the
audience wants to know how did you
because to sing about these things you
got to love these and you have to with
full conviction believe in it how did
you come to this thing that you really
submitted yourself in a sound okay
actually it's a story because when I
when I was young I used to like to sing
all the time yeah but my family my
friends and family hated my voice you
know they said that you know just like
shut up don't say your legs I'm so bad
and but I actually you know just like
just loves to you so I didn't listen to
anybody yeah and when I graduated from
college
well let's say when I was in school one
of my friends hearing me reciting the
Quran and he said to me that you know
what why don't you recite the Quran in
the morning assembly and I was like no
way
you know I'm like I have nerve restoring
like front of thousand students what he
did he told one of my teachers and my
teacher told me that you have to come in
otherwise you know you'll be trouble so
I didn't go I was I was actually excited
and I I did actually I didn't recite the
Quran and assembly morning assembly and
it's felt good that people accept me and
they like my voice after that when I
went to college I astray but you know
and you know the college is just for his
life the friends and
and it's not so much into the the deal
and I graduated from before I graduate I
heard Nasheed single and I like this
voice so much and and he didn't use any
any instruments yeah but he had all this
mixing and vocals all around him and
everything and I was like wow how could
he do that and I never thought one day I
would be doing the same thing I'm gonna
take better yeah but I'm gonna say that
I wouldn't be doing the same thing and
he was like my my Isley know I wouldn't
wanted to meet him and you know so I
graduated and when I started working
with my dad my brother had a studio my
brother is a is a Karakorum he tried to
come on and he had a studio which he
used it to record some of his quran
reading and then he also used it to make
some more machines or some songs yes so
there was some group of guys they came
and they made the song and he told me
like if you're free why don't you come
over and help me with the sound new year
I said okay I'm gonna help you like you
know just like fix the sound everything
I never came to my mind that I'm gonna
be one day no stocks not that sitting
behind the instruments I'm gonna be
actually singing singing so I went and
started helping him you know the levels
and with the microphone and everything
and then I told my brother honestly what
they're doing does not actually appeal
to me you know I mean even to the
Blessed a people you will not be able to
to attract them with this because if you
want to give them something before I
want them to hear your message has to be
something nice something which they
would say way let me listen to the
decision and then they will hear it so
he told me okay he challenged me
actually if you have something you know
just bring it on I said I don't I don't
sing another singer then I thought about
it I said okay let me go back home and I
started like looking through the books
and see if I can't find one poem I did
find a poem it's about it's also about
like how much person complains and I
mean I composed the music for it and
after two weeks I told my brother I'm
ready
I want to sing good yeah and he said to
me that no I was just kidding
and I said no come on I'm ready so said
okay I'll give you a chance so he I
really give me a chance I I just think
and the guys were there they they just
loved the song and then I said to myself
okay I'm gonna like I'm gonna help you
with the with the album I'm gonna be
like a like like a part of the album
this one song or two songs when the
album was released the production
company said that do you know we want
Airmen to do another one yeah so I said
okay it's still something which I didn't
think that it would be you know
something we do like I'm doing right now
so I did another album which was called
conscious calling us and I had four
songs in that and from that album people
started calling the let's say the
production company and asking him that
we want more albums for airman then I
actually went and and I did this so solo
album suppose first at the end till now
I've been as 2x around seven albums as
their yes and so that that's the way
after that when I third album like my
sister told me that her friend she
listens to my music and she cries when
she listens to it there was a one but
one song says that it's about about life
about dunya and how that we are today
living in dunya and tomorrow will not be
here yeah you know we'll be in our
graves and the how does this life is so
tricky you know if you don't if you
don't do good you can just find yourself
one day
you didn't do anything good and you know
and God knows were what would happen you
know qiyamah so she went when she told
me about that I felt so sorry for her
and I felt that you know my god this is
my cause this is what I have to do I
have to you know I have to let know know
what is actually affecting the people
around me and try to bring a solution
for them yes to my songs and hundred let
it happen
it helped a lot because I sang about the
the mother
I sang about
La Scala I sang about ethics I sang
about the sable people I sang about even
diseases for example this was a disease
called thalassemia disease and it was
not we were not aware and then and you a
or let's say back home that this disease
was even existed it was actually you
know the people dying from this disease
you know and and now after we made this
big campaign and I made this song now it
is mandatory in UE that you have to take
the test of the last human before
getting married yeah so you see so
you're singing about a lot of good stuff
tell us I've got a chance to interview
some of the famous former rappers we're
out there with Sean Sean P Diddy Combs
with jay-z and with Tupac some of these
people and now they're out there and
they're trying to let that youth no
that's not the direction to go
what advice do you have for the youth or
stuck taking those musicians as role
models 50 cents to park and all the
other rappers that are calling tonight
good things like your songs are calling
too but they're calling too evil
corruption fornication swearing and
cursing everything bad and if you follow
them you're going to be the worst of the
worst so what because you have the
attention of many of them big
responsibility so the youth and a lot of
people look up to you so those people
who now need some advice what advice
would you give them well life is short
okay and if you don't actually wake up
you know and start doing good and being
good in this life you would end up you
know just like the rest if you see many
many people before us you know from the
time of Moses Valley Salaam Pharaoh and
and all these people who passed
Hospitaller has has shoulders in the
Koran that what did these people get
people were they were kings they were
they had money they had so much of power
but because they just followed the bad
you know undo and they wanted to be you
know they had this
pride and they didn't want to listen to
their messengers and the last mile at
the end they ended up they lost
everything they ended up in hell and I
mean that is the case which we would
have we have to actually you know look
at this that this is a life and I have
got a chance to pick the right way you
know if I pick the wrong way it's not
just it's not just it's going to be I'm
gonna be bad I'm gonna affect the people
around me you know I'm gonna be
responsible for that for them you know
but if I'm gonna be good I'm gonna go in
the good way I'm gonna be giving you no
peace and I'm gonna be given that no
land that lie to everybody around me I'm
gonna help people and this is what I
actually advise the youth as to you know
go back to themselves go back to Allah
subhana Allah
you know see what they can give to this
this world what can what can they offer
as I said life is too short
we're gonna take a break do what our
brothers talk about I'll just close your
eyes do some with the song and he tried
to do it scary about that don't complain
so until we come back just close your
eyes see what it feels like to be blind
and we're gonna come back with more and
we'll continue and wrap it up here in
the D shop no problem
you can take my daughter to dinner you
and my daughter and me let me tell you
something it's naturally just created
and he created us to have a good time
you should have a good time
what he was a wise though Islam is the
fastest growing religion in the world
and most of the converts are women not
men they see that the rules of Islam
instead of constraining it the rules set
them free
and as I left he said to me I thank you
you've been so kind you will see he said
Oh God forgive me when
when
I have to
the world is back here on the Dean show
with my brother ahead now open your eyes
okay and you got your eyes and you got
both your legs what else you'd have to
complain about
don't complain and that's your song it
talks about we're almost out of time
talk to us you have a song about death
yes talk to us a little bit about this
song it's called last breath last breath
yes tell us about this song this song is
about that this person he all his life
he did not do any good in his life and
suddenly there was this last breath and
I said you can't if you can't look we
could breathe that's a blessing but
that's it you're talking about done no
more air no more air that that said
finished there's a motel work finish no
more repentance on what happens well
you're alive you got a chance to repent
exactly go ahead Nick so this guy is
feeling sorry for him so huh that you
know that he didn't pray he didn't do
good in his life you know he wasn't good
to his mom and dad he wasn't good to his
wife let's say you know he wasn't they
just went the he was a straight he went
to the wrong way and now that his last
breath is gone he just would have to go
down in the grave and get you know get
get only what he has done at the moment
would be accountable for you know so he
was he was so sorry for himself and he
was telling us come on my brothers let
us pray decide which side now is gonna
be hell or heaven you know so this song
it's telling us we have to decide now is
it we're going to choose that a good way
or gonna choose the bad way because once
we are in the grave and that's it it's
finished done now can you give us a
treat is it possible you just explained
the song but we have just a minute left
can you give us a treat and this is that
song what do you think can can I hear
from you yeah sure
go ahead please take it away from those
around I hear a cry a muffled song a
hopeless I I hear their footsteps
leaving slow and then I know my soul
must flood a chilly wind begins to blow
within my soul from head to toe and then
last breath escapes my lips it's time to
leave and I must go so it is true but
it's too late they said each soul as its
given day when it must leave it body's
so and meet with us eternal fate
Oh mark the words that I do say who
knows tomorrow could be old day at last
it's gone I'm so happy no he'll decide
which now do not delay come on my
brothers let us pray decide which now do
not delay come on my brother's little
aspirin decide which one do you
mashallah mashallah God willed it
thank you very much may God Almighty
Allah reward you for being with us thank
you so much for coming today much thank
you mark my words as I might say I'm
gonna chop up the words but you get the
meaning to-morrow today can be your last
day so come on my brothers let's pray
let's worship the One God alone and then
establish the prayer do the good stop
complaining you got so much good in your
life isn't it time that you started
being thankful if you got $100 from some
how you say thank for you the person
gives you a cup of water a cup of tea
thank you sir but the Creator is giving
you so much you cannot enumerate all the
blessings he's given you so be thankful
be happy and start to do the good that
the crater's called you to do we'll see
you next time here on the Deen show
until then peace be unto you
I
from those I'll go here then footsteps
leaving slow and then I know my soul
a chilly wind begins to blow within my
soul from head to toe their last breath
escapes - it's time to leave and I must
go so it's too late in the name when it
must leave its buddies for and me
Twitter's internal
who knows tomorrow might be your day at
last it comes to heaven under the Sun
which now
my brother's sighs come on my brother's
man uh spray this side and I'm gonna be
God Allah I cannot see eyes everyone
wants to leave or heads my soul bananas
create forced open eyes me we are way to
learn some shower
me for the night push your that came my
turn
no words for they though the words that
I don't say who knows tomorrow happy
my brother's no come on my brothers let
us pray you decide